it is a tragic end that friends and
family had feared three lives lost after
a night of partying
Eve Smith and Darcy Ross both 21 and 24
year old Raphael John died Sophie
russson and Shane Lachlan remain in a
critical condition in hospital
the three women reportedly went to the
muffler Social Club in mice class in
Newport on Friday night they then
traveled around 38 miles to treco Bay in
a car with two men the five of them are
last seen at around 2 A.M on Saturday in
a clanadehan area of Cardiff later that
day family members contact police and
begin appealing for help on social media
to try and find them police then find
their vehicle while searching along the
a48 instant melons near Cardiff shortly
after midnight on Monday morning some 48
hours later
they're such youngsters and you know the
whole lives ahead of them and it's a
shark a Devastation
um very upsetting
throughout the day many people have been
coming down to lay flowers and read the
tributes but amongst the community of
the friends and the family and those
living nearby there are big questions
about just how these five people were
undiscovered just meters away from this
main road for so long
gwent and South Wales police have
already referred themselves to the
police Watchdog The iopc Specialist
officers are working to piece together
just what happened here
answers may come in a future inquest
none of which will bring back these
three young lives
down Whitehead Sky News in Cardiff